for all of you guys listening on the
radio I am sorry because I'm listening
to Marshall Faulk and Jerry West talk
about golf and Chris Brockman's like
giggling over there in the corner
because this conversation is so epic
that I know we're gonna talk basketball
but I feel like I'm shipping people by
not letting them listen in on this
little golf
yeah Jerry you said something so
important which is that if all kids got
hooked on golf they wouldn't get in
trouble and I think you're probably
dead-on well you know what it teaches
you a lot I think that you know we all
don't grow up in perfect circumstances
and I think when you get on a golf
course around people who play golf it's
a real gentlemen's game and I used to be
involved a little bit in golf here in
Southern California and I would go to
see some of these young kids oh my gosh
how polite how you know how their
parents they were they were like young
professionals real boys and and young
girls they just had a such a fantastic
way about them that you felt like this
is maybe could be a turning point in in
life and in terms of how they interacted
with people how generous and kind they
were to people and you'd like to see a
lot more of that today than then we see
that for sure you know you know Suze to
two things for me with golf first when I
started to play I started playing golf
like my second year in the league and
golf taught me how to to deal with the
things that I did wrong so if I fumbled
the ball it didn't mean that I was a
formular it just happened in golf like
if you you just have to you have to
accept what happens if you hit a ball
you hook it into the water out of bounds
you literally have to stand up there and
and and make the same swing with the
same thoughts you can't try to change
things it's just that's what happened on
that one swing it's not going to happen
again and it taught me to accept things
within my sport and not not like take it
personal just move on you know the next
shot the next play and then the other
thing about golf that I love
and and I think think about this think
about if in every sport you had to do
this in golf you call penalties on
yourself mm-hmm
just think about it guy goes up for the
game-winning shot you hit his elbow you
go to the ref hey I hit his elbow or in
football you grab a guy a Jersey he
drops the ball hey ref I grab this
Jersey everyone say it's an offensive in
golf you call penalties on yourself that
would solve a lot of the NFL's
officiating issues I think we're on to
something we're gonna get ed read a head
coaching job or at least a DC and we're
gonna change NFL officiating in this one
show I should do the show every day
problems you know I saw something happen
in a basketball game and I'm not sure
it's permissible that we can talk about
other players but a truly great player
who I really admire a lot shot to air
balls in a game
well national TV the other night and I
don't dare mention his game and say I
love him as a player he's really great
and I don't think either one of them
touch them he'll it don't even sound
right I'll get fine for saying but I
love this player I wait plays I love the
way handling so and I wonder what what
his thinking was when he would get back
at the free-throw line again and this
guy's not good
he's all-pro he's really great but he's
shot two air balls
hold on they didn't they don't either
one him I don't think touch the net that
with Shaquille half the time he didn't
shoot air balls okay here's where a
little thing ever you're looking at
Clank and had more of a clanking sound
it's bananas oh my god I think we can
all fill in the blanks here but you know
for decorum and because Weaver you you
can you could probably go on on on some
platform and put two air balls in Oh
whoa and it'll come on come up first
people at home can do the homework later
that I really I think he's young oh my
goodness what a player he is well that
being said we do thank you for coming in
because you are hurt because you are on
the I art because you have bronchitis
I'm gonna go ahead and ask you a couple
questions we'll lay off on the guessing
game for what's happening Jerry West of
course here on the Rich Eisen show Susie
Schuster Marshall Faulk in this Hall of
Fame Edition starting out a Hall of
Famer guys I apologize maybe someday
right in Rich's world right Doc Rivers
talks about being at Nobu Malibu when he
heard that they big Clippers trade came
down when he guys knew that you'd have
Kawhi Leonard and Paul George where were
you when you got the news that was in
Las Vegas I knew we were really close
and I think doc was on your show I know
he talked about it
I knew we're really close but we had
when I say we our front office Lawrence
Frank michael winger they're the ones
who should get the credit you know I
think there was a plan in place to try
to be able to talk to free-agency found
attractive and during that period of
time we had a great meeting with Hawaii
did not know whether or not that he
would come here but he would had a great
meeting with him and as I say he talked
about our roster and he mentioned one
player in particular and that player was
Paul George and you know we our friend
office gave a lot to get him and we
ended up in crying him and I walked into
the summer league and somebody said I
can't believe you guys got both of those
guys it was very happy night for all of
us and you know we'll we'll see what the
outcome of the season would be but I
think if you have two players like that
on your team it really gives you a
chance because there are premier players
on both ends of the court and watching
Hawaii had had a chance to really
practice that much watching do we do
things he's he's not good he's one of
the major stars in the game today
major I wouldn't be surprised if he
would if this clipper team can ascend
and be a threat going into the playoffs
that he would he would not be the most
valuable player but also we have had
Paul George around and he is a he is in
his own right he is kind of like Hawaii
but quiet is different and to have two
players like that on your team is pretty
remarkable summer and my hats off to our
front office a remarkable job how what's
the status on Paul George well he's just
about there and you know we have not
shot the ball very well I think we've
won game because of at this point in
time because of quasi brilliance on both
ends of the court I might add and he's
showing me a dimension that I didn't
know he had before you know if we should
have been shooting the ball a little bit
better he might be leading the league in
assists he is remarkable he's funny but
boy is he competitive when you look at
where the league is today you you've
built other teams and you've had a lot
to do well what's what's that what's the
the difference in how they used to do it
to it nowaday how you're building teams
well it's much more complex today
because you know last year there were 21
teams that have an enormous amount of
money to spend and I think at the end of
summer there was like one point almost
1.7 billion dollars spent on players
hours but I've always felt that cap
space is fool's gold
because sooner or later you're going to
have to spend it and if you're under the
threshold where the league requires you
to spend X amount of dollars you have to
spend it on someone and some teams will
pay someone you know and in his orbit
amount of money for two years this
certainly should not be in the category
of these truly great players and you
know there's always one or two prizes
out there every year and people were
already out we're gonna go get these
guys we're gonna go get these guys it is
really difficult and it's difficult to
maintain teams today because of free
agency and I think kids today have
choice when we played when you played
you had no choice and football players
have little or no choice today anyway
yeah they probably got the worst
collective bargaining agreement deal
that I've ever seen in my life
for a sport that that's risky and that
dangerous and basketball has been
blessed with some great leaders who have
grown this growing the fortunes for
players today because the increasing
popularity this league not just in this
country but worldwide and I'm thrilled
for the players
people say oh he makes too much I don't
care how much money they make I don't
I'm thrilled for him because for
everyone who's overpaid we've had a lot
that are underpaid so I would probably
be a a great advocate for stronger
unions for the players today the
franchise's in a franchise talk about
how much money they make but at the end
of the day there was enormous write-off
for for these very rich owners and
they're more concerned the new owners
know about numbers sometimes numbers
matter more to them players matter more
to me well what about your new owner and
Jerry west of course Hall of Famer Jerry
West joining us on the Rich Eisen show
with Hall of Famer Marshall Faulk and
myself Susie Schuster your owner Steve
Ballmer seems to be the polar opposite
from you as you said to me yesterday you
don't like being pampered you don't like
attention I think you almost seemed to
be embarrassed by being referred to as
the logo and you've got a an owner who
is like literally like shaking up a can
of soda and boom off you go so what's
the appellation ship like well I will
tell you Susie he has two different
personalities he's unbelievably
competitive and some people don't like
competition they like it one way he is
really competitive but without a doubt
he's one of the most common men I've
ever met in my life and that's his charm
the enormous amount of money that he
gives away because he and his wife ortho
philanthropic it's amazing but he you
would never know that he had
kind of resources he does he's a giver
what he does it's kept quiet except his
enthusiasm and he he's a pleasure he's a
breath of fresh air to be around I've
never you know I've been involved with
three fans with late Jerry Buss who was
remarkable himself he was a a man of the
people
Mike Hisey in Memphis very much like
Jerry a little bit more boisterous he
has the same kind of personality that
Steve does and being around Steve as
really as I mentioned breath of fresh
air it's just he's just an amazing guy
he wants to build his own arena
obviously there's opposition to it and I
think he should be able to build his own
arena unfortunately I won't be around at
that time to watch it but I just I wish
there were more owners like him what are
you going I'm going off and watch mark
I'm gonna be his caddy
I'm just saying where are you going I
think we all have a shelf life
regardless of what we do and it's not
you know this is I've had a charm life I
really have to be able to work for a
storied franchise play for a storage
franchise I worked for an incredible
owner and Jerry Buss who believed in me
and gave me an opportunity something
that most people would say you know
because you're an athlete you can't do
it you can't think on that level I will
always be grateful for him in the Laker
franchise the icon Jerry West here on
the Rich Eisen show so you bring up the
Lakers and we now have a situation where
there are bona fide uh stars on either
side when when I worked with you so much
when I covered the Lakers from 2000 to
2003 the joke was the little brothers of
in the Courtney Hill O'Neal still on TNT
a couple weeks ago referred to the
Clippers as the little brothers that's
not the case anymore what's it like for
you who was so synonymous with the
Lakers to see this rivalry be an
actuality now well you know I'll just
say because of the history of the Lakers
I'm not sure this will ever be a
I think if the in the last seven years
the Clippers have had much more success
but you would never know that people
history is established by something that
is it's unprecedented and the number of
championships and the incredible amount
of great players that played there the
greatest in the game the play for the
Lakers trust me there's more great
players at play for the Lakers than
anyone and to be part of part of that
history was was so much fun but to be
involved with Gerry and again a man the
people he was brilliantly gifted
mentally you know he wanted basketball
to be more of an event and then then and
then a sport and he changed the
landscape of the sport particularly talk
radio right well a few people know it
but he was claimed ticket was his first
invention and but he established
different ticking a ticket pricing got
the celebrities to come the game and so
the Lakers have a completely different
following than the Clippers the Lakers
would be you know the franchise that
people have have really embraced and
wisely so and the Clippers would
probably appeal to towns like Pittsburgh
yeah New York City tough hard-nosed kids
and in New York I you know I don't know
how people play there with it with the
enormous amount of criticism you get
here in Los Angeles most of the time the
players I mean the press is pretty
pretty easy to deal with but the
enormity of the talk shows these
bloggers and and I know you hear a
marshal talking about a football I don't
think anyone knows what it's like to
carry the ball 24 times and wake up what
you feel like the next morning I see
somebody five feet four and no you know
no criticism someone five feet four talk
about what it's like to play in a
basketball game and the pressure you
feel
the pressure to win a football where you
have 16 games they want to expand it to
17 paying more money of course I hope
but with basketball
the enormous season and then it's like a
marathon and then the last 28 games if
you play them all that's when you're
gonna establish what a franchise history
is gonna be and the Lakers did that
better than anyone for quite a while so
I I was I agree with you on that there's
there's no way that you can compare them
to but I believe that there's a fight
right now the Clippers are putting up a
fight for LA to be recognized and to be
identified in LA and that's that's what
I see it's not it's not you're not gonna
take LA from the Lakers
no but you could put up a fight and
that's what I see I see a fight being
put up well you know I just say it will
be really interesting the basketball
fans in Los Angeles will be the lucky
ones that's for sure and this would be
kind of a showcase all year to watch
these two teams and they're gonna be
showing on TV a lot of time you LeBron
James and his swagger that he plays the
game the the following he has and the
fun guy Kawhi Leonard just sitting there
staring yes I kind of liked that by the
way you know what tell us something that
we don't know about Kawhi because he is
kind of like a he's a mysterious figure
in the NBA he doesn't overshare
he doesn't seem to have a need to put
everything in his life out there well
it's just his personality and when
you're around him when you're around him
he's very quiet but when he starts
talking he is really funny and he's
absolutely charming and you know this
Terminator movie that he I'm not I mean
this I guess it's an advertisement for
the new Terminator movie to watch him
there
that almost to some extent looks like
it's uncomfortable for him but I think
he enjoyed it but the one I enjoy is a
car that he has driving looks like on
Mulholland Drive
oh gosh that that is incredible that's
incredible New Balance shoe commercial
do you have time to stick around for
another segment different Marshalls here
all the mercial goes there Marshall
Faulk Susie Schuester Jerry West here on
the Rich Eisen show stick around let's
talk to you Jerry West in a moment about
Michael Jordan's comments on Steph Curry
and whether or not he thinks he's a
hall-of-famer looking forward to hearing
that when we come back here on the Rich
Eisen show DirecTV has college football
in 4k HDR with lifelike picture quality
Richard colors four times the resolution
of HD makes sure to tune in tomorrow at
2:30 p.m. to catch Virginia Tech and
number 16 Notre Dame on DirecTV for K
channel 105 if you don't have it go to
AT&T comm slash isin 4k and don't ask
words about it because of course Notre
Dame lost to Michigan so now he's just
[ __ ] of the walk it's a that's a whole
to do we're nervous in our house Jerry
riches which is his temperature his mood
changes and swings rapidly with Ohio
State looming I have to say I'm gonna
like Sue's hide the knives tell me the
feeling when the kid dropped the ball
against Penn State on fourth down what
what was what I just was every time
something like that happened you think
what yeah I'm like you know where his
eyes and what is he doing like who's
holding him right now like did you have
the coddle I got the tylenol with
codeine and I gave it to him with a
little bit of whiskey and I said as I
turned the corner and talk about
medicating my husband Suze Shuster
Marshall Faulk with you here
Jerry in the last segment we talked
about for a second Michael Jordan saying
that Steph Curry is not a hall-of-famer
yet now you're very close to MJ clearly
your Coast and you're close to Steph
Curry as well what's your take on that
well I think he's so Michael reaction he
smiled and I think he knows he's a
hall-of-famer but he has not been
selected yet but he will be getting in
basketballs hall of fame today has
really changed okay
it's a this the standards have been
lowered some because they're trying to
expand the role of basketball worldwide
but Steph Curry is a no brainer
okay I think Michael knows that how
would I was handling it if Michael
Jordan said that if I was stuff and I'm
just saying Mike said that about me I
wouldn't even feel slighted I'd be like
okay Mike Mike knows my name right not
only that but I still have games to play
like if your career was over and Mike
said that about you you need to be
worried I think it was all
tongue-in-cheek if you know Michael
Jordan and know how he's playful okay
he knows how Steph Curry I'll take a bet
that he's a hall-of-famer period playing
basketball right now as are the number
but he was changed a game like stiff
stuff changed the game well the game has
been changed for a lot of reasons I
Marshall the three-point lines
completely change a game and also all
the analytical people have changed a lot
and I watch the game sometimes and I see
80 some free throws I mean a them threes
a shot and I say to myself how can you
be a great defensive team unless you
have some kind of a balance because
they'll go down the chute one on four
and here comes the offensive team
running this way and a long rebound a
lot of times they just throw it down for
a wide-open layup so I think your
defenses get compromised but the
analytical people have gotten so
involved today that it's not a game I
think is as pretty as I'd like to see it
I'm probably more of a purist I think
because the advent of of the three-point
line we see more people taking
three-point shots but I think when
they're taken is the most important
thing because to me it gives you a
little bit better balance defensively
and gives us a team a chance to play
defense where sometimes you just can't
play good defense and when the ball was
shot so from everywhere I mean
absolutely everywhere and
as I say it creates excitement because
late in the game the lead is never safe
it's created a different kind of player
we see incredibly gifted ball handlers
today that are you know like James
Harden unbelievable offensive player and
I think to watch him play that in what
Steph Curry play you watch all the kids
now they don't ever shoot from freezer
line they're all shooting behind the
three-point line when they ran when
you're younger you emulate people you to
admire and to see him on TV and make
shots that you know so he's it's a
greatest shoot of all time he probably
is I don't think it's close but to watch
him shoot around before the game I mean
you know some guy will go out make eight
or ten or he make thirty or forty or
fifty and in klay Thompson do the same
darn thing and they're on one team it's
beautiful to watch when you can shoot it
like that Jerry thank you so much for
coming in sick I couldn't appreciate it
more we really appreciate your time
Jerry West here on the Rich Eisen show
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app